une forêt de pins tout en haut d'un joli
village viticole de la côte d'or mais
aussi le clown ap orléans et la rue
noiseau de nom indissociable à fils 1
qui révèle un lieu inattendu en
bourgogne le fort empereur une réplique
miniature du bastion au napoléon
bonaparte a vécu lors de son exil sur
l'île d'elbe
ce bâtiment aujourd'hui un musée a été
construit par un grenadier de la garde
impériale claude noiseau originaire
dawson tout au long de sa vie cet homme
qui vouait un véritable culte napoléon
1er à amasser des objets liés à la vie
de l'empereur dans cette vitrine
vous pouvez voir deux bicornes de type
1814 et de type garde impériale qui ont
été récemment restauré grâce à des
mécénat privé
vous avez aussi ici un magnifique
coffret à couture qui a été donné par
l'impératrice joséphine des tableaux des
gravures des médailles
un véritable cabinet de curiosités
choses insolites clown oiseaux
collectionnait aussi toutes les terres
de bataille qui là qu'on a retrouvés
dans des petites boîtes et annoter tout
à noter lausannoise on n'était pas qu'un
soldat il était aussi artiste peintre
doué d'un excellent coup de crayon comme
le prouvent ses carnets de croquis
après la défaite de waterloo il est allé
à paris pour exercer son talent de deux
peintres et gagner sa vie en vendant les
heures effectuées c'est dans le parc
planté de pins laricio apporter de corse
un parc de 5 ha totalement créé et
aménagé par claude loiseau que se trouve
l'oeuvre la plus importante dédiée à la
gloire de napoléon
[Musique]
un monument conçu par claude loiseau et
son grand ami le sculpteur dijonnais
françois rude très attaché lui aussi à
napoléon 1er nous sommes exactement à
l'endroit le plus connu du parquet
noiseau où se situe l'oeuvre de françois
rue nez de clown oiseaux le réveil de
napoléon face à l'immortalité
à quelques mètres de là le buste de
françois rude veille sur la statue le
grenadier claude loiseau lui repose un
peu plus loin mais il n'a pas été inhumé
2 blue sa paupière comme il le
souhaitait à l'époque on n'avait pas les
moyens de le creuser aussi profondément
la roche donc il est incliné face à son
empereur le parc est ouvert au public
tout au long de l'année
quant au musée il se visite de la mi mai
à la mi septembre les samedis et
dimanches après midi